so
hi i'm nick gillespie for reason tv and
today we're talking with kevin
williamson the
deputy managing editor of the national
review and also the author of the new
book
the politically incorrect guide to
socialism kevin thanks for talking
and define socialism uh for us well
two parts uh one is the public provision
of non-public goods
and the other is the use of central
planning to get that done what is a
non-public good
a non-public good is something that
could be uh privately priced and
consumed in the context of this
education is something that is provided
by the state but it doesn't need to be
so right education would be a really
good example of that but there are
things that are i mean the sort of
classical public goods are things like
national defense and law enforcement but
there are lots of other examples too and
they vary from context to context one of
the things i get into is uh
in india they have public campaigns for
mosquito spraying and ddt which you
can't do here
but because they have horrible problems
with dengue fever in the cities so that
would be a pretty good example of a true
public good
that probably needs to be publicly
provided economic uh
central planning um what would you give
me uh from history what's the worst case
scenario
stalin's russia not so great hitler's
germany not so great
today's north korea pretty bad you talk
a lot about sweden
and why it fails it's socialist in
certain ways but we're not really
talking about the state actually owning
the means of production
right sweden is the one country everyone
always wants to talk about when you talk
about socialism because it's a terribly
attractive place everyone's you know
tall and blonde and they live a long
time and they're healthy and all that
stuff
sweden's not really that socialistic a
country sweden is a country with a big
welfare state and high taxes but that's
not the same thing as socialism because
what sweden doesn't have your right
is a very strong element of of central
planning of the economy sweden is
actually very enterprising very free
trade
oriented country the places where they
do have a lot of socialism in the
economy are mostly in the labor
sector and there is a lot of direct
government management of that and that
tends to be the most dysfunctional part
of their society
you talk in the book about um socialism
and the environment what's the effect of
socialism
on the environment when there's no
property it's hard to
it's hard to secure people's rights it's
sort of like the way the state on
state-owned oil companies work you know
if bp screws up in the gulf you can sue
them
you can capture damages and things like
that if it's sign a pack which is owned
by the
you know government of china well good
luck unless you're willing to invade
they've got nuclear weapons you know you
can't really police them arguably the
the single biggest reason that air
quality in the united states is better
now than it was 30 or 40 years ago is
because of the mandated switch from
leaded to unleaded gasoline
um is that socialism and if it is is it
so bad
that's just regulation i mean there's a
great deal of socialistic
tendencies in uh in the american energy
market we're dealing with things like
gas
you've got things like the pickens plan
which would require that everyone use
natural gas and then give them a great
big subsidy to convert over to doing it
organized by a guy who has vast holdings
of national natural gas i mean that's
just
you know it's it's that's exactly where
central planning goes wrong right
because someone's got different
incentives than you do always uh now in
the book you say flat out that obamacare
that the president's healthcare reform
plan
is socialist uh explain how that's
that's not an overstatement because it's
based on the premise of the government
planning
outcomes in the marketplace and it's and
it happens at this level of statistical
abstraction where they came in and said
well the united states spends x
percentage of gdp on health care
and switzerland spends less than x and
therefore we're going to have a federal
policy that's going to manage healthcare
production and consumption
in order to bring it down below the
statistical level and we're also going
to get better outcomes and we're also
going to share millions more people
while lowering prices
so it's got all the sort of rocks what
could possibly go wrong so it's not
socialism in the sense that say the
public schools are socialism
because the government's not going to
own the hospitals and clinics and things
like that
but it will uh set prices through things
like medicare and the other entitlement
programs
it'll probably get involved you know
directly in setting prices of things
like prescription drugs um procedure
prices are pretty much now established
at the government level
so you don't actually have to take over
the factory if you can just act as
though you own the factory what's the
continuing romance of socialism i mean
you know the 20th century even
even pbs said the 20th century was a
battle between hayek and
central planning and that hayek won so
who who is still rooting for socialism
and why i think
it's a form of perpetual adolescence
you know when you're going through
adolescence it's usually the part in
your parents life where they're working
the hardest and doing the most business
and making the most money
and people who never grow out of
adolescents start to in some way
i think associate that you know sort of
thriftiness enterprise
hard work all these boring bourgeois
values that make the world
bearable and they project it into the
world at large as they grow up and
it's driven by history of the rich it's
immaturity it's ignorance
and it's envy kevin williamson
deputy managing editor of national
review online and the author
of the politically incorrect guide to
socialism thanks for talking thanks nick
i'm nick gillespie for reason tv
you